all right let's do this hopefully today
I can actually use my brains and I can
actually use my words because last
couple of times it just didn't really
work out and there were terrible miss
happenings when it comes to the videos
and things it was just it was just awful
but in any case we should be back
alright at this point I was doing the
live stream and just happily placing
buildings as I always am but it didn't
really work out that well all the time
so there are actually a couple of cuts
here and there to make some custom
scenery because I wanted to get some
Amsterdam facades at least that's sort
of how I went into it but I do have to
add to that that I did make these
facades much lower and well just much
smaller than the Amsterdam facades that
you would have since it really just
wouldn't fit within the scale of the
theme park so they are really down
scaled when you compare them to real
Amsterdam facades I suppose it's not
really like Amsterdam
I know Amsterdam is the most well-known
City but just take any sort of city with
about 100,000 inhabitants or something
like that in the Netherlands and that's
about the sort of heights that these
buildings would have just like a smaller
sort of City and not the huge facades
that Amsterdam would have and for that I
just needed a couple of really small
simple scenery pieces because like I
said this is barely anything out there
that actually has the touch scenery in
there so I I can't really take credit
for it because they're absolutely awful
pieces has nothing really in it but I
did pick up that really good brick
texture which didn't really work out
there and of course I wanted to start
working on clock gables that you would
find in Amsterdam but that was just a
complete and utter fail but there were
actually some other Gables that that
sort of work out so in the end it's it's
alright and I also have to get some
different windows in because there's
just no good windows for this stuff
either I don't know if I'm gonna have to
do this for every single every single
part of the park because honestly I'm
not really feeling that but then again
the Dutch theme is just something that
hasn't really been done too much in this
sort of way at least not that I know of
if anybody knows of a certain Park and
made em rollercoaster country that does
have the specific Dutch theme then I
wouldn't really like to see that because
I might actually get some inspiration
Pramod but I have actually never seen it
all so one really random thing that I
just wanted to throw out there is that
yeah in episode 90 I think I didn't
mention like some things that weren't
rights like the Spanish area of Europa
Park consisting out of just one building
it's just what I looked up and that's
what I found
I suppose I'm terrible at searching
things anyway that is completely wrong
and it turns out to be an actual larger
Mile Park part of the park than just ATS
but regardless it is a bit different
from this park and something that I also
got is some comments like not being
entirely sure what this entire idea is
about for this park concerning the
different parts of the park and then
having the same themes along the main
square I'm gonna try to actually explain
it right here and not completely suck at
explaining it the basic idea is that you
do go through these different parts of
different parts of the world in the park
and the main square basically has
buildings that represent each part of
the world along the main square that's
basically how that sort of works but
it's just going to be one building just
one simple facade just to kind of show
along the main square what sort of areas
that really are in this Park and where
you can find them and the problem
currently just still is how I can
actually blend that in well with the
areas that are here because obviously
the English area is tucked away all is
like tucked away and the corner of the
park expect the English anyway who
really gives a [ __ ] about them I might
even put the I might even put it on an
island seriously but in any case it's
just so far away from the main square
that I'm worried about
even being able to fit a English looking
building along the main square in and
actually make that look all right while
also maintaining the Spanish looking
thing that the Spanish area still has
going on but that's something to really
think about later on I haven't really
explained too much about these Amsterdam
facades I don't know if any if any
people out there are not too familiar
with it I know that a very large section
of my Furies is actually Dutch so that
should be alright but the main thing
that I needed to think about is one that
is actually know
main thing really when it comes to
Amsterdam facades that I had to think
about actually many things one thing is
that they all have to be like at the
same distance from the path itself so
there's no messing with different
placements of the buildings this is
something that I really got comments
about is the fact that this facade is
very flats every single building is just
connected without any corners around it
no building really sticks out more than
the other ones no building is really
tucked away further from the path and
the other ones it's just one big
straight line of buildings essentially
if you just take away all the different
textures it would be one building almost
with just different roofs on it and
that's something that I really just
couldn't avoid for realism purposes
buildings in Amsterdam are actually
really simple and the rest goes for much
of the buildings in Holland many of the
buildings in Holland whoops and that's
basically why I just had to do it like
that but that does mean that I had to
get different textures in there and
these red brick textures no not too many
of them involve coasts I can through yet
so I had to make two different brick
textures to kind of make that fit in I
think there is also a tiny bit of all
those sets
there's the grenades and the Pat's
efteling set sort of war stucco thing
whatever that even is but it looks
alright so I went with that as well and
another thing is that the windows are
all the same and this is something that
I was actually quite shocked to see
well not exactly shocked it doesn't
shock me to see Windows but I was quite
surprised to see that Amsterdam windows
are very very similar that they just
spam the same window all over the place
and that was just something that
realistically I just wanted to do in
this park as well and the windows are
religious simple and just rectangular
windows with nothing to them and white
and I think all the windows had white
frames so that's something that I really
wanted to get in there and that's pretty
much that and building to time stirred
am are basically just simple really
simple buildings with nothing to the
walls and nothing to the window is the
only special and very signature thing
that I do have going on as those Gables
so you have the stair Gables and the
clock gables and whatever sorts of
Gables that even are by the way I was
building a bridge over there which was a
really bad idea I do want to try and
make
a suspension bridge knowing me that's
probably gonna fail miserably but still
I want to try it at some point in time
but in any case that's like what I just
said about the buildings was the moat
the things that I really just wanted to
take care of and keep in mind while I
was building those things and I don't
know how well I really succeeded when it
comes to that I must say I'm really
happy about the buildings especially
considering that I haven't really done
the theme before and there was no real
guideline that I had beforehand but so
far they just really look very dead and
no idea what I'm going to actually fill
them in with because one pretty damn
important thing to make your building to
look less dead is of course get a
something to like actually make them
functional and this is something that I
see many people forget but just simple
signs simple flags some chairs outside
just the sign of life inside the
building is something that is so very
necessary when you're doing buildings in
a theme park because even if they aren't
real you like the small details that
make it look like it's actually real and
there's actually people inside or that
there's some some sort of activity is
something that you I would actually like
to see so the signs assuming that I
still want to work on at some point in
time just a sign different sorts of
shops two different buildings speaking
of that I might just get a coffee shop
in one of these buildings like honestly
it's it's a [ __ ] theme park in Veliko
stick in three am I really going to give
too much of a [ __ ] about what is really
going on within the park so I might just
sort of make a small coffee shop not not
that I would like sell weed in it that's
a terrible idea but I don't know wheat
lollipops or something that that would
be an all right thing for a theme park
wouldn't it be I think it would be
alright plus that's erm that's that's
the only bad thing like what what's
Amsterdam known for what do people go to
for Amsterdam they don't come from the
for the facades well they come for the
Bursar's but not the facades that I'm
typically building in Veliko sticking
three and the weed of course so that's
pretty much what I'm probably gonna have
to work on in the park as well there I'm
not I'm definitely not gonna get
prostitutes over here and
spike so what sort of things I really
want to do in those besides it's gonna
be pretty tough maybe just two shops and
the entire row of facades but in any
case this general area is just going to
be a couple of buildings just a tiny bit
of scenery one ride at least that's the
current planning but not much more I've
seen so many people just ask for a rides
in the Dutch area which is something
that I would have liked to do as well
but it's something that well for one I
didn't really feel like I would be able
to pull it off well and there's also the
fact that it's really just a bit of a
transition area and there and there is
not enough space over here at the moment
and I don't want to completely redo
everything and make that work somehow oh
and this thing by the way because it's
been building for quite a while but I
haven't even talked about it is a train
station which is sort of inspired by
both a train station in The Hague and in
Amsterdam and that's pretty much what's
going on over there but it's just a tiny
bit of an experiment it's inspired by
these stations but really not the same
but it does have these same the same
sort of style which would be two towers
on the sides with the nice little spires
so that's always nice but this is
definitely something that I have to get
back to laters if there really aren't
any good details for this kind of
building and I will get back to that
later because yeah I see that my time is
about to be up so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys later at
some point in the future I hope that
that's not going to take too long but I
need to get my house and actually work
on this poker game except I'm doing
quite a bit of summer showdown stuff
lately and going to London also wasn't
exactly great for my upload schedule so
I'll try to work on that for a tiny bit
so peace with the [ __ ] I never I never
say peace and no idea where that came
from just somehow